WAY!
ROUND ONE, GAME ONE OF T EDLER D
MIKE SMITH MAKES THE FIRST SAVE
OF THE SERIES!
SPENCE FROM THE BLUE LINE.
KALIYEV SHOOTS!
SMITH FINDS THE PUCK AND HE
COVERS UP!RE GETS AWAY FROM MIK
AND LIZOTTE HAS AN EXCELLENT
OILERS, THE THIRD BEST
HERE'S ANOTHER SHOT THAT JUST
SKIPPED BY IN FRO
WORK HIS WAY RIGHT BACK DOWN IN
TO THE MIX.
THIS PUCK COLLISION WITH IT.
KRIS RUSSELL NUT OF THIS LINEUP.
THIS RIM AROUND THE BOARDS
DOESN'T GET.
THE PHYSICALITY.
IT'S BEEN A PHYSICAL ONE ALREADY
BUT IT LOO L.A. OR McDAVID...
MOVING IN WITH SPEED!
HE SHOOTS, HE SCORES!
>> Louie: WELL, GUESS WHO,
CONNOR
IN, WAS UNABLE TO DO SO.
HERE'S McDAVID TO BARRIE FRO
FUNNY BOUNCE.
BARRIE HAS IT UP TOP.
DRAISAITL DOWN LOW. ACROBATIC A
DISPLAY!
>> Louie: I'LL TELL YOU, HE WAS
DOWN, JUMPS UP
WITH THE CHEST TO MAKE THAT ONE
AND
YOU GET STICKS IN THE
ASSISTS ON YAMAMOTO'S GOAL.
HERE COMES CONNOR Mc
AND YOU CAN SEE HIM GO THROUGH
BOTH DEFENCEMEN, PUT IT BACK.
SHOOT, ONE TIMER FROM BARRIE
BLOCKED BY DANAU
STICK AND THAT STICK GETS
DROPPED DOWN ON THEND DRAISAITL
FING HE SAID THE MORE
DURZI MOVES UP. ON THE
STICK, WAS ONE HANDING IT MOSTLY
AFTER THAT. IN A PLAYOFF
GAME.
BUT IF ANYBODY KNOWS ABOUT
IAFALLO.
DUMPS IT IN.
PUCK STOPPED BEHIND THE NETAKES.
TRAFFIC I